I read it,
wrote,
read a very interesting book awhile back
called the wealth and poverty of nations
that was written by a Harvard emeritus
professor of history and one of the
things that he claimed I liked it.
I thought it was very smart,
was that the only true natural
resources,
interpersonal trust.
If you can set up a society where people
trust each other,
then it will instantly become rich.
And he used the example of Japan,
which is a very conscientious society
and very rich society,
but the Japanese have no natural
resources,
right?
None to speak of and yet the rich and
then you have countries like the Soviet
Russia and much of South America where
there's just natural resources,
but you know,
they're just like Venezuela.
Just more natural resources.
Then you know what to do with and the
places are absolute catastrophes.
My absolute catastrophes of cynicism and
corruption.
And so he attempted to document the
relationship between default
interpersonal trust among citizens
within countries and their,
their productivity in their,
their GDP and their standard of living
and found a very,
very tight relationship.
And,
and I liked that a lot and I've got a
story about that quickly that I think is
very interesting.
I'll tell you two stories.
One sort of generic,
I'll tell you one personal first.
So one day I lend my car to one of my
graduate students and he took it to
Montreal,
is this old Cadillac and he got it was a
really bad rainstorm in Montreal and he
was in one of the highways that are like
set into the ground and it was like six
inches of water and he was turning a
corner,
hit the brakes and skidded on the water
and smacked it into the wall and on the
corner of the,
of the bumper,
you know.
And so then he brought it back and he
was very apologetic about it.
And,
and uh,
his name was matt shade tell you that
because Matt might hear this and I can
shame them and bit for doing this 20
years ago,
you know,
and uh,
he's a professor at the Ontario
Institute of Technology I think now and
quite a successful one.
But anyways,
he brought the car back and I went and
got it evaluated for damages,
it was like $1,700
or something to repair it and,
or maybe more,
but it was almost as much as the car was
worth.
And I thought,
well I'm not gonna do that.
So I went online and I typed in the part
and uh,
if you do that you can get people to bid
on sending you used part from all over
North America.
So that's Kinda cool.
So there's all these junk dealers have
got together and they have this network
of communication.
So you put in the car part and then they
send you a bit.
And so this guy said,
well,
I'll send you that bumper assembly,
which is the whole bumper and the lights
for like 250 bucks.
And I thought,
yeah,
okay,
you could do that,
that'd be good.
So then I said yes.
And then he called me up about half an
hour later if this guy from way down
south,
he had a really deep sort of Mississippi
accent and he said,
wait a sec,
was that for the bumper or the bumper
assembly?
And I said,
well,
it was for the bumper assembly.
He said,
oh,
I thought it was for the bumper.
And then he said,
but that's okay.
I'll send it to you anyways.
And I thought,
well that's pretty good.
So said,
well thank you.
And then I hung up and then half an hour
later he called me up again and he said,
look,
I just went out and looked at that
bumper assembly and there's a plastic
trim piece on the side and it has a
scratch in it.
And I thought,
I better tell you that just in case you
didn't want it.
And I thought,
wow,
that's so amazing.
It's like there's a miracle man.
It's like this guy,
he's somewhere in Mississippi.
I'm never going to see him again.
Ever.
Never gonna have any contact with them.
Like he made a bad deal.
Right?
Because the part was worth more than he
decided to sell it to me for,
but he stuck with this deal and then he
went over and above the call of duty.
He said,
well,
this part that I'm selling you to you
for way less than it's worth is damaged.
So I thought I'd better tell you.
It's like,
man,
you got to recognize a miracle when you
see one that was a miracle.
So I said,
hey look,
it's thanks for calling man.
So okay,
I can handle the scratch.
Send the part.
And he did and I got the car fixed and
forgave Matt and you know,
it had a happy ending.
So.
So that's trust,
right?
Because I didn't know him from Adam and
he's a primate full of snakes just like
the rest of us.
And yet he was willing to simplify
himself to the point where I could just
take him absolutely at his word.
And that meant we could trade even
though we were strangers.
It's like,
man,
do not underestimate the utility of
that.
And then there's Ebay.
When Ebay first started,
you know the idea was not gonna work
because you'll send me junk and all send
you a check that bounces and that'll be
the end of Ebay,
right,
and so these escrow agents popped up so
you could insure your transaction with
them moves for like 10 percent of the
transaction.
They would get the check and the goods
and make sure that they were okay and
then send them on or ensure the
transaction,
but what happened was the escrow agents
didn't make any money and the reason for
that was no one cheated.
You think about how amazing that is,
right?
You bring these people together across a
whole continent.
They've never seen each other before.
They're never going to interact with
each other again,
and this was before there were any
reputation ratings on Ebay,
and yet the default transaction was you
describe your goods honestly,
including their flaws.
You set a reasonable price.
I decided to pay you.
You ship the goods and I pay you,
and it works.
And what happened was that Ebay
produced,
it produced a tremendous amount of
capital that was previously frozen,
so frozen capitalist.
When you've invested money in something
but the thing is no longer useful to
you,
so the money is just sitting there
frozen,
right,
so to speak,
and you can't get it loose because,
well,
you've got an attic full of junk.
How are you gonna?
Get rid of that.
Oh,
E bay.
And so all of a sudden all these things
that were just junk became valuable and
everybody got richer and none of that
wouldn't.
It would have happened without the
covenant that we established between
each other that's predicated on trust.
And so you might say that trust is the
currency and currency is trust because
it's a promissory note,
right?
And if people lie,
then the currency gets debased very,
very rapidly.
And so the economy runs on trust.